y encontré una manera de hacer la Web disponible a través de una voz sintetizada
lo que simplificó radicalmente la interfaz de usuario.
Esto me llevó a desarrollar el Home Page Reader en 1997
primero en japonés y, a continuación, disponible y traducido en 11 idiomas.
Cuando desarrollé el Home Page Reader,
recibí muchos comentarios de los usuarios.
Recuerdo uno en particular, que decía:
"Para mí, Internet es una pequeña ventana al mundo".
Fue un momento revolucionario para la gente ciega.
El mundo cibernético se volvió accesible,
y esta tecnología que hemos creado para los ciegos tuvo muchas aplicaciones,
mucho más allá de lo que yo había imaginado.
Puede ayudar a los conductores escuchar sus mensajes de correo electrónico
o que le puede ayudar en la lectura de una receta mientras cocina.
Hoy soy más independiente,
pero esto todavía no es suficiente.
Por ejemplo, cuando subí al escenario necesité ayuda.
Mi meta es llegar aquí sola.
Y no solo aquí.
Mi objetivo es viajar y hacer cosas que son simples para ustedes.
Ahora les mostraré las últimas tecnologías.
Aquí es una aplicación de teléfono inteligente
en la que trabajamos.
(Video) Voz electrónica: 15,5 metros hasta la puerta, en línea recta.
Hay dos puertas para salir. La puerta está a la derecha.
Se acerca Nick, parece muy contento.
Chieko Asakawa: ¡Hola, Nick!
(Risas)
CA: ¿Dónde vas? Te veo muy feliz.
Nick: Oh, mi artículo acaba de ser aceptado.
CA: ¡Eso es genial! Felicitaciones.
Nick: Gracias. Pero, ¿cómo sabías que era yo y que estaba feliz?
(Chieko y Nick se ríen)
Hombre: Hola.
(Risas)
CA: Oh... Hola.
VE: No está hablando con usted, sino por teléfono.
Patatas fritas.
Chocolate negro con almendras.
Engordaste 2 kilos y medio desde ayer, come una manzana en lugar de chocolate.
(Risas)
Te estás acercando.
Has llegado.
CA: Ahora...
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Esta aplicación me guía,
en base al análisis de señales de baliza y sensores de teléfonos inteligentes
y me permite moverme en espacios interiores y exteriores
de una manera independiente.
Pero la parte de visión asistida por computador que indica quien se acerca
y con qué estado de ánimo; todavía trabajamos en esto.
Reconocer las expresiones faciales es muy importante para ser sociable.
Así que la fusión de las tecnologías está lista para ayudarme
ver el mundo real.
Se llama la asistencia cognitiva.
Comprende el mundo que nos rodea
y susurra la información en mi oído o envía vibraciones a mis dedos.
La asistencia cognitiva aumentará
aquellas capacidades que faltan o están deficientes,
en otras palabras, los cinco sentidos.
Esta tecnología se encuentra todavía en su infancia,
pero un día seré capaz de encontrar un aula de clase en el campus,
comprar con solo mirar el escaparate
o encontrar un buen restaurante con solo caminar por la calle.
Será genial verles por la calle antes de que Uds. me vean.
Esta herramienta va a ser mi mejor amigo, y la de Uds.
Realmente es un gran reto.
Es un reto que requiere colaboración
y es por ello que estamos creando una comunidad abierta
que acelerará la fase de investigación.
Esta mañana hemos anunciado la tecnología central de código abierto
tal y como se vio en el video.
La frontera es la realidad.
La comunidad de los ciegos está explorando esta frontera técnica
y el dispositivo de guía.
Espero trabajar con Uds. para explorar esta nueva era
y la próxima vez que esté en un escenario
espero, gracias a la tecnología y la innovación,
ser capaz de llegar hasta aquí
por mi misma.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)